a smile costs nothing
but gives much
be more concerned with your character
than with your reputation
for your character is what you are
while your reputation is merely what
others
think you are
fear doesn't exist anywhere
except in the mind
if you want to change people why not
begin on yourself
that is a lot more profitable and a lot
less dangerous
knowledge isn't power until it is
applied
develop success from failures
discouragement and failure are two of
the surest stepping stones to success
people are not interested in you
they are not interested in me
they are interested in themselves
morning
noon
and after dinner
of course your husband has a lot of
drawbacks
if he had none
he would never marry you
when fate hands you lemons
make lemonade
criticisms are like homing pigeons
they always return home
most of the important things in the
world have been accomplished by people
who have kept on trying when there
seemed to be no hope at all
the desire for the feeling of importance
is one of the chief distinguishing
differences between mankind
and the
animals the expression one wears on
one's face is far more important than
the clothes one wears on one's back
success is getting what you want
happiness is wanting what you get
listening carefully to a person is the
greatest compliment we can give him
the load of tomorrow added to that of
yesterday
carried today
makes the strongest falter
the successful man will profit from his
mistakes
and try again in a different way
people sometimes became in villains in
order to win sympathy and attention
and get a feeling of importance
do the hard jobs first
the easy jobs will take care of
themselves
the gun that scatters too much does not
bag the birds
man is not made to understand life
but to live it
smile
today
is the tomorrow you worried about
yesterday
always make the other person happy
about doing the thing you suggest
keep busy it's the cheapest kind of
medicine there is on this earth
and one of the best
rarely succeed
unless they have fun in what they are
doing
our thoughts make us what we are
to be interesting
be interested
one reason why birds and horses are not
unhappy
is because they are not trying to
impress other birds and horses
happiness doesn't depend on any external
conditions
it is governed by our mental attitude
only knowledge that is used sticks in
your mind
you cannot teach a man anything
you can only help him to find it within
himself
a person's name
is to that person the sweetest and most
important sound in any language
if you want to gather honey
don't kick over the beehive
personally
i am very fond of strawberries and cream
but i have found that for some strange
reason
fish prefer worms
so when i went fishing
i didn't think about what i wanted
i thought about what fish wanted
by all means take thought for tomorrow
yes
careful thought and planning and
preparation
but have no anxiety
two men looked out from prison bars
one saw the mud
the other saw stars
talk to someone about themselves and
they'll listen for hours
there's only one way to get the best of
an argument
and that is to avoid it
criticism is dangerous because it wounds
a person's pride
hurts his sense of importance
and arouses resentment
remember
happiness doesn't depend upon who you
are or what you have
it depends solely upon what you think
you can make more friends in two months
by becoming interested in other people
than you can in two years by trying to
get other people interested in you
our fatigue
is often caused not by work
but by worry
frustration
and resentment
if you want to keep happiness
you have to share it
any fool can criticize condemn and
complain
and most fools do
you will never achieve real success
unless you like what you're doing
ask yourself what is the worst that can
happen
then prepare to accept it
then proceed to improve on the worst
happiness is not mostly pleasure it is
mostly victory
flaming enthusiasm backed up by horse
sense and persistence
is the quality that most frequently
makes for success
every successful person loves the game
the chance to prove his worth
to excel
to win
inaction breeds doubt in fear
action breeds confidence and courage
if you want to conquer fear do not sit
home and think about it
go out and get busy
people are more likely to accept an
order if they had a part in the decision
that caused the order to be issued
arouse in the other person
an eager want
he who can do this has the whole world
with him
take a chance
all life is a chance
the man who goes furthest is generally
the one who was willing to do and dare
success in dealing with people depends
on a sympathetic grasp of the other
person's viewpoint
feeling sorry for yourself
and your present condition
is not only a waste of energy
but the worst habit you could possibly
have
if you can't sleep then get up and do
something instead of lying there and
worrying it's the worry that gets you
not the loss of sleep
every man is a damn fool for at least
five minutes every day
wisdom consists in not exceeding that
limit
influencing others is not a matter of
outsmarting them
it is a matter of discerning what they
truly want
and offering it to them in a mutually
beneficial package
pay less attention to what men say
just watch what they do
act as if you were already happy
and that will tend to make you happy
it isn't what you have or who you are or
where you are or what you are doing that
makes you happy or unhappy
it is what you think about
people don't have many friends
because as kids they didn't learn to
trust people
the only way to influence people is to
talk in terms of what the other person
wants
three-fourths of the people you will
ever meet are hungry and thirsty for
sympathy
give it to them
and they will love you
try to pretend to be a fool and you'll
get the whole truth from a man
an individual who unselfishly tries to
serve others has an enormous advantage
are you bored with life
then throw yourself into some work you
believe in with all your heart
live for it
die for it
and you will find happiness that you had
thought could never be yours
let's not allow ourselves to be upset by
small things we should despise and
forget
remember
life is too short to be little
for many centuries
nobles and magnates supported artists
musicians and authors
so that their creative works would be
dedicated to them
everything that is in agreement with our
personal desires seems true
everything that is not
puts us into a rage